This is me sprinkling a secret
ingredient ...
Bam!
on some dumplings I'm
making for my roommates.
That ingredient is:
but I'm not gonna tell them that
because I know a lot of folks are still afraid of MSG
which is short for:
It's a savory,
satisfying seasoning
that's in a lot of things you
probably eat every day
like chips, canned soup and KFC.
But for some reason when it's used in
East Asian cuisine.
especially Chinese food people
freak out.
There was even a condition named after it :
Chinese Restaurant
Syndrome.
Some symptoms supposedly included:
heart palpitations, headache, chest pain
But study after study has shown
MSG isn't the cause of any of these symptoms.
The FDA, the EU and the UN all say it's safe to eat.
And we certainly don't hear about
1.4 billion people in China
experiencing any side effects.
So why do so many people think
MSG is a dangerous ingredient?
And why was Chinese food
targeted?
The late Anthony Bourdain had one theory:
I decided to investigate by eating, cooking
and breathing MSG for a few days.
Hi, I'm Yara.
And I absolutely love Chinese
food.
I eat a lot.
But I've never experienced this so-called Chinese Restaurant Syndrome ever.
So I went to New York ...
to meet a Chinese American chef who isn't shy about publicly using MSG.
And he has a rad Brooklyn accent.
Hi, I'm Chris.
Chris is known for his dumplings.
This is incredible.
And uses MSG specifically in his stir frys.
So we poured some raw MSG out on the
table.
And I tasted this one kind
And then this MSG filled chicken powder.
If you go to diners where they have soup,
they're not boiling bones for eight
hours, they're using this.
But you don't come out of there saying,
"I have a headache."
This stuff is so damn tasty, but why?
Monosodium glutamate is one part sodium
and one part glutamic acid.
When it dissolves in your mouth the two separate
and once that glutamic acid is free
it causes a flavor explosion on your tongue.
And brings out a unique hyper-savory,
meaty taste that consumes your whole mouth.
That taste is called umami.
Aside from sweet, sour, salty and bitter
it's the fifth flavor the human tongue
can sense.
And it was discovered by Japanese scientist
who basically extracted MSG from seaweed in 1908.
And that Umami flavor bomb, that free,
unshackled glutamic acid,
is also naturally found in things like
tomatoes
mushrooms
and Parmesan cheese.
But MSG in its powdered form
that's basically pure,
unadulterated umami.
Chefs these days love adding umami to their food,
which is what we did.
And then we sprinkled on one final source of umami:
It's as a finisher.
You wanna just ... a little bit.
And use it sparingly.
When I was in China though they
were a little bit more generous.
I was always a little bit, a
little cheap with it.
And they'd go:
Scoop, right?
That's so good.
Absolutely nothing happened.
No headaches no palpitations, no
nausea.
If you go to China and you go to the supermarkets in China,
you're gonna see aisles of MSG
like you would see here for cereal.
We're talking about MSG,
there's a little bit of
... to it.
You know some of the older
crowd come over,
and they'll be right to your face.
They'll be like, "You don't cook
with that MSG stuff do you?"
"I know you're from China, but you're in America now,
so you got to do things the way we like it."
But how did MSG come to get such
a bad rap?
I wanted to know
is there actually any definitive science that
links MSG
to those negative symptoms we've read about?
And Dr. Ken Lee is gonna help us get
to the bottom of that science.
Yara, please call me Ken.
Alright.
Ken is a food scientist with a passion for MSG.
And New York's Chinatown is
his old stomping ground.
That used to be my uncle's meat market it's now a poke bowl.
Whaaat?
Did your parents cook with MSG?
Absolutely. It's just like salt and
pepper.
MSG is an essential ingredient of Chinese cooking.
Is there any like double-blind scientific study
that proves any of the health symptoms?
I can say absolutely not.
In a scientific study where people don't
know what they're eating,
so they're fed msg or a placebo, meaning sugar pill,
Sure.
People on the sugar pill develop symptoms as well.
It could even be psychosomatic.
A little bit of chemistry here,
glutamic acid is a component of protein, okay?
You and I are both made out of protein.
It's already in you.
Yeah it's in you too and it's in
everyone that's watching this video.
So how did the stigma against MSG come
about?
In 1968, a Chinese-American doctor wrote a letter to a major scientific journal.
He claimed that whenever he ate at Chinese restaurants in the U.S. he experienced:
numbness all over his body,
general weakness and heart palpitations.
His letter was titled "Chinese Restaurant Syndrome."
He suggested it could be caused
by a number of things including MSG.
Readers then wrote in talking about their own symptoms and scientists started studying it too.
But a lot of the initial research was faulty.
Scientists messed up by:
assuming MSG was already the culprit,
using ridiculously high doses of it
and failing to use placebos
properly.
But it was one study in 1969 that caused a massive panic.
If famously injected MSG under the skin of mice
leading them to develop brain lesions.
No human would actually consume MSG that way?
No, but actually a good point.
If you just took common table salt and injected it under your skin you could induce a real toxic state.
Right.
Solid scientific research came out debunking MSG myths in the next few decades.
But it was too late,
"no MSG" signs had already popped up
around the country.
Everybody hears the accusation and nobody tunes in when they hear the verdict of not guilty.
So that's what happened
with MSG.
It's amazing just one letter
a bunch of flawed science and an entire
cuisine, an entire people, stigmatized.
But here's the thing there's a huge double
standard.
We actually eat lots of non-Chinese foods with MSG,
but you don't hear about people getting sick from them.
We're gonna go pick up some foods and snacks that have MSG in them very openly.
All of these have MSG in them.
However when it's in these it doesn't seem to generate a controversy.
You won't find a label on any of these products, you know, "MSG free"
because MSG is accepted as a Generally Recognized As Safe substance by the Food and Drug Administration.
What are you feeling?
A Dorito.
Doritos? Okay.
Clink.
Oh God.
I'm not having any reaction.
Is there like a small percentage of people that have reactions?
Yeah, absolutely.
What's more likely they're reacting to other ingredients that are in that wonton soup
or whatever they attributed the MSG to.
Why do we distrust foods like MSG
because it's used extensively by Asians?
It's just ignorance.
So if MSG is in all these Western foods why do people freak out when it's in Chinese cuisine?
I met up with Sarah Lohman
Sarah wrote a book about the eight
flavors that make American cuisine
and MSG is one of them.
We met up with her at the Museum of Food and Drink,
which has an exhibit on Chinese food and MSG.
MSG is to savory as like a sour patch kid is to sour.
It's like the most pure form
of savory.
This is the bowl of MSG right?
Yes. Should try it?
Yeah let's do a little ...
Nothing happened.
But first we had to order some Chinese takeout.
Is the food here?
– The food is here.
Oh my God!
Yes!
So, Sarah explained.
Like that's xenophobic.
You're essentially blaming an immigrant culture
for making people sick.
A lot of racism against other cultures revolves
around this idea that
like you're not even
human.
Look at what you're eating it's full of this poison MSG.
But how did MSG
get to the U.S. in the first place.
After it was discovered in Japan MSG made its
way to China became super popular.
And Chinese immigrants then brought it
with them across the Pacific
But one of the main ways MSG actually entered
America was through canned food.
By the 1930s, the U.S. had become one of the largest buyers of MSG in the world.
And the seasoning eventually found its way into military rations, condiments, TV dinners, you name it.
The major consumers of MSG in this country aren't Chinese restaurants
it's American processed food.
Every brand from Kraft a Kentucky Fried Chicken.
And I've never heard someone say that they have Doritos syndrome, that is not happening.
Americans like to blame
immigrants for things.
When Italian immigrants first came here they were villainized for their use of garlic
and garlic was – I know it's laughable right
now what American doesn't cook with garlic
– the smell the flavor was really
symbolic of not wanting to become American.
Four, five, six generations later
we love Italian food.
So could MSG one day be as widely accepted as garlic?
Perhaps, but there's a long way to go.
The stigma is still very much here,
which is why a lot of chefs are still hesitant to use it at their restaurants.
And that's why we're here to talk to Chef Lien.
– Hi.
Hi.
She runs a ...
modern Vietnamese restaurant.
Lien and her family are from Vietnam
but their ethnically Chinese and came
to the U.S. as refugees.
My parents cooked with MSG so I'm very
familiar with the ingredient,
but as a professional chef growing up in the
industry,
because of a stigma, there was a lot of pressure not to use the MSG.
Lien is afraid that she'll lose clientele if she starts using MSG in her restaurant,
but she still finds other ways to add
umami to her food.
Add a little bit of fish sauce. Now you got some umami in there. Yeah?
And the stigma against MSG has even touched
Lin's family.
Her dad still uses it,
but her mom doesn't cook with it anymore.
So, we went to Lynn's house to cook with her parents.
You cook together with your wife.
Yeah.
That's so nice.
High five! Yeah.
You don't use msg in cooking today?
No. Somebody said MSG is not very good.
I like this disagreement between mom and dad.
Then we cooked two
dishes, one with MSG ...
Alright, here it comes. Yeah!
And one without ...
to see which one tastes better.
Let's try without.
OK.
Yeah this one definitely has I think a
little more fuller feel to it.
Kind of coats your mouth. It really brings out the other flavors that are in there.
I can't imagine if like food from my culture,
if I had to tell everyone like
"Oh I've had to remove an ingredient from it." you
know?
I feel like that would just be really sad day  for me.
The experiment we did at Lien's house of course brings me back to the experiment I started the video with:
secretly feeding MSG to my roommates.
So what's the deal with these dumplings? What's in them?
So, I basically put one teaspoon of this into the filling of those dumplings.
One teaspoon per dumpling?
No, no, no.
One teaspoon in the entire dumpling filling.
I mean it's a great flavor.
How do you feel after eating MSG?
Perfectly fine.
Satiated, satisfied.
My roommates loved the taste and didn't get sick.
And of course they didn't
because well the science says MSG is perfectly
safe.
What I learned by making this video
is that people are afraid of MSG for a
number of reasons.
There's the initial flawed research, there's the rumor
mongering or ...
But things are looking up.
A new generation of Asian-American chefs are taking back the narrative.
So I hope the next time you
order some Chinese takeout
and someone starts talking about getting a
headache or something else
You'll be able to tell them
it's not the wonton soup
and it's not the MSG,
it's probably just in your head.
I hope I've convinced you guys there's nothing to fear about MSG
but that doesn't mean you should just go about dumping tons of it all over your food.
Just like salt, or really anything in life, consume it in moderation.
Anyway share this video with friends and family who think they get headaches from MSG
and see how they react.